leota's legacy lives on with the cast of
his apple tv plus series blackbird
honoring his work at the los angeles
premiere
yes the crime drama features rey's final
tv appearance with stars karen edgerton
paul walker or paul walter
hauser and greg kinnear sharing what it
was like working with the acting legend
take a look we'll see you next week
i did have
a special connection with him for the
short time that i knew him and he was it
felt like we were at the start of a
friendship and um
i'm very very sad that he's not here to
celebrate this with her with us ray
liotta uh the one and only i i grew up a
huge fan of field of dreams and then as
i got older i watched copland and narc
and goodfellas and i just
i think he's so brilliant and in this
show like i'm not just saying it because
he's passed on i'm saying ray liotta
is one of the true highlights of this
show and he makes it he's so good i had
never worked with him and i was a fan
from way back before i was an actor i
saw him in a movie i loved and
didn't know what to expect he was lovely
he's
a great spirit and uh hard-working
guy a guy who cares about his work guy
who cared about his art guy who cared
about the truth